well this comment section is going to be
fun so just the other day I put up a
video talking about the new Netflix
series iron fist that's coming out soon
and just basically sort of rambling my
thoughts on what if the early reviews
are guys accurate and the thing sucks
pretty much I combined my conversations
with just my general thoughts about how
it might have gotten that Marvel
actually would put out a product that is
of notably lower quality than than other
stuff they put out and what that might
mean going forward one thing I made a
real point of not bringing up was the
cast and the race of the lead character
of Danny Rand the iron fist
the reason I didn't bring that up is
because honestly I am really kind of
burned out on the whole racial thing
after I mentioned it in my last ghost in
the shell' thing and the comments
section turned into just a cesspool
but despite making a point of not
bringing that up
in my last Iron Fist video it got
brought up in the comments section
anyway so you know what if you guys are
going to sling this crap in my comment
section no matter what then at least I'm
going to say my piece now before I get
started I'm going to say this even
though I know it won't matter the people
who are really adamant on either side of
this argument they are going to stay
that way and they are going to be
needlessly vicious regardless but one
thing I'm going to make a really big
point of not doing in this video is
talking in absolutes because I don't I
don't believe in absolutes very much in
general and I certainly don't when it
comes to these sorts of situations
there's a lot of nuances a lot of
context and people come in going it's
always this or it's never this or it
should always be this I don't I don't
like to be on those kinds of terms
because there will always be exceptions
do anything that always should or always
shouldn't be the case but let's talk
about this casting and let's get right
down to it so we are talking about the
character of Danny Rand aka the iron
fist now Danny Rand in the show and in
the comics is white and he has always
been white in the comics so having him
cast as white is truer to the original
source material that's one thing to keep
in mind now
I am NOT absolutely beholden to specific
things I think you can change anything
as long as you have a reason to do it
the source material no matter what it is
whether it's a book a comic an earlier
film or whatever is not a holy text but
if you can remain true to the overall
thing you can change any number of
things you can change anything really as
long as you can maintain the integrity
of the piece so the question becomes if
they were going to recast them what they
would what would they every chasm as
would that have caused new problems
would that afix some problems what are
the pluses and minuses going into this
now I'm going to really narrow it down
and I'm going to say like the options
were basically either leave him white
which again is true to the original
comic books or to make him Chinese or
chinese-american now I'm not saying he
absolutely would have had to have been
Chinese but I'm going with that because
iron fist is inspired by kung fu and
kung fu' movies kung fu as a Chinese
martial art that entire sort of genre of
film is more Chinese than anything else
but I eat I'm going to use that term
Chinese but I'm not necessarily saying
that it couldn't have been Japanese or
Korean or whatever just sort of roll
with me as I use that term I understand
I'm not saying rigidly that's the only
thing it could have been because I mean
realistically where this thing is that
in the comments that's a made-up country
it's a made-up martial arts and I
understand that but just let's move
forward or we're never going to get done
so there are the options so in terms of
keeping him white as I said Shores are
the source material are there problems
with keeping him white actually yeah the
big one which I think a lot of people
who want is the character to be recast
as Chinese a chinese-american were quick
to bring up is that Danny ran kind of
fits the what is kind of known as the
white Saviour motif which is it's a very
old trope in really kind of any story to
any Western storytelling and it's a
problematic one is one that as a society
we kind of have moved away from but it's
not that's a fairly recent development
so you know going back to a character
was created in the 70s like Danny ran
was
you're going to run into this kind of
thing so just to recap quickly in case
you don't know what that term means is
when a character who is white and is
presumed to be a surrogate for the
audience and this is a trouble that
dates back to really the only people who
could read because this would have taken
up you know more in written stories were
white people so it was safe to assume
that whoever was reading the story was
white and that the white person would be
their pob character but you send them
into this other society this other world
and they are brought in and embraced and
they they are revered even within this
culture that they have no place in it's
been around for a long time if you want
some examples just to kind of latch on
to the Tom Cruise will be the Last
Samurai Dances with Wolves really any
adventure story written in say the 1910s
or early or that stuff is steeped in
this and even if the character doesn't
like to become some sort of magical
mystical like gain the powers of this
culture they're still the story is still
being filtered through their eyes still
through the lens of the white character
even if they aren't made into a savior
figure and in terms of properly valuing
a culture that is a non-white culture
that is a bit of a problem it's a very
patronizing way to tell a story so
that's the first problem the other one
which I think some people brought and
there's a more minor one so I'll move on
it quickly is glad Danny Rand it looks a
lot like Batman and I don't mean in
terms of the actual look but I mean you
look at that first teaser that we got
Brian Prison that felt a lot like Batman
like well like Batman Begins
specifically which I think at this point
it's safe to say is the dominant image
of Batman's origin in the popular
culture right now so lots of parents
wealthy white kid you know in this
secluded mountainous region of the you
know of the world learn how to fight and
comes back and kicks crimes but and
retakes his family's company that that
is true of both and I think recasting
Danny as a Chinese of chinese-american
have been one less thing that parallels
between the two so if Disney had gone
with a Chinese American actor they would
have lost the white Savior angle they
would have differentiated from Batman at
least superficially a little bit more
and now the question becomes would there
have been any issues with casting
chinese-american what I've seen people
bring up is the idea that as part of his
training Danny ran didn't fit in this
place where you where you know his
family had the plane and crashes his
parents died and he was taken in and
raised and trained but he didn't belong
there and he had a sometimes
antagonistic relationship with some of
the people involved in his training and
that's kind of important to the
character depending on the direction you
actually want to go with him and I've
seen some people make the argument that
you lose that if he is the same
ethnicity as the people training him and
I would say that yes but there's a way
around that so if fantastic
chinese-american yes he would have been
the same race as the people who were
training him but he would not have been
from the same culture because if he
never lived in China or in that part of
the world and wasn't raised in that
culture and was just raised you know
like anyone born in America was then
rather than being a racial clash it
becomes a culture clash I think you can
still hit a lot of the same antagonistic
beats and in terms of them looking down
on him not having the same respect to
him based on a different than culture
and not necessarily meaning a difference
in race to be able to do that although
speaking of him being raised and the
culture and all of that there is one
thing that they would have to time to
figure out a way to address if he was to
not be white because to make the Batman
comparison again Bruce Wayne being white
eliminates the need to have to explain
the fact that his family's rich there's
a lot of rich white families around and
there have been for a long time old
money we get it and Danny ran ties the
same thing now if he was a
chinese-american there would have to be
some kind of explanation as to how he
came to be in the position he is in
terms of his family owned the company
because there really isn't much in the
way of this sort of multi-generational
you know established big money in just
that culture and America of people of
that race
one requires some degree of explanation
it wouldn't need a ton of time I mean it
could be as simple as his dad was white
his mother was Chinese and you catch the
Chinese American actor and go well he
took more after his mother so there are
ways around it but I think that would
require being addressed in some fashion
that's just a logistics thing so right
now it is looking a bit like it just
would have been a way better idea if
Disney had just made the leap and recast
him as a chinese-american so are there
any problems with doing that yeah
actually there are there's a big one and
it has to do with stereotyping so it's
getting rather than white sure we lose
the white Saviour angle but what we gain
is a walky stereotype all yeah Chinese
superhero of course he does kung-fu aha
what else was it going to be and the
thing is it's very obvious that Marvel
and Disney are aware Assyrian had to be
being a problem when we've seen that
with the changes that they made to the
Mandarin and the ancient one in both
case they were characters that were
originally Asian and when brought to
film were played by actors who don't
racially look like the characters did on
the page but part of the reason I don't
think it was the only one but I have no
doubt that part of the reason that
Marvel have made that decision to make
those changes is because those
characters and their original comic book
incarnations are walking stereotypes the
matter is basically fu-manchu's with
magic rings and the ancient one is just
every ancient Chinese secret
you know mentor teaching the ancient
ways figure that you've seen in every
kung-fu movie ever now I don't think
avoiding those stereotypes was the only
reason that those characters were
changing I don't want to spend a ton of
Tainan time on them but it doesn't seem
to need that Marvel and Disney are very
much aware that they are sometimes
bringing characters to life that have
issues with being stereotypes and so I
can see why that would probably be part
of the calculation if it was ever a
discussion in their offices that would
go be a knock against making Danny Rand
chinese-american because suddenly he is
a stereotype so if you're still with me
at this point I
going to propose that basically we've
got almost equal level problems I don't
want to have debate as to whether a
stereotypical race-based character is
more offensive or in some way less
offensive or a better or worse than a
white save your character I don't know
what the greater offense is in my mind
you could make a case for either one so
I'm going to call it right now we've got
problems on both and so it seems like
we'll flip a coin it doesn't seem to
make a difference we're in trouble
either way so we got to open it up
bigger we got to bring in more context
and by going bigger picture I mean let's
talk about representation because if we
basically come down to look having him
be white has problems having him be
Chinese has problems then we kind of
gotta go who needs the representation
more and I think that's a really easy
call there are fewer examples of strong
heroic Chinese characters in American
made pop culture material for that
entire racial group or anyone who feels
the connection to that racial group to
be able to look up to they kind of need
it more and I think all in a lot of ways
it comes down to the question even
though the representation that a Chinese
American Iron Fist would have offered
would not have been ideal because it
would have been stereotypical is it
better to have a stereotypical
representation or no representation and
I would make the argument that the
stereotypical representation is the
better of those two options that that's
all you've got to pick from because when
you've got no representation there's
really nowhere for you to go if you have
representation but it's stereotypical
and problematic you can push it into a
better direction and I'll use some
examples from pop culture you look at
the explosion of blaxploitation cinema
in the 70s you look at those films the
representation of blacks in those movies
is not flattering at all they are
violent misogynistic their pimps and
their drug dealers I mean it looks awful
but it put more and more and more black
faces in cinemas in front of people so
that from there they were able to go
okay we have to move beyond that and
then we started getting more nuanced
characters for black actors and I think
you can vest money
a flute and you can see that with other
minorities as well there was a really
big explosion of gay themes material
sort of in the early 2000s yet Will &
Grace and Queer Eye for the straight guy
in the Bravo Channel which is really
heavily focused on LGBT as a demographic
and in terms of what they're putting out
there all kind of came about at the same
time you go back and look at most of
most left up its stereotypes to hell I
mean there's all these gay characters
but they're either you know missing
little Queens or they're you know the
Oscar Wilde kind of thing and they're
incredibly stereotypical but they're a
starting place you get representation
there first and maybe it's not the best
but you can push to make it better if
you're not represented at all then
you've got nowhere to move forward on so
once you bring that into the discussion
I do think honestly Disney would have
been better off making Danny ran a
chinese-americans and leaving him white
now I don't think there was any
conspiracy or any degree of blatant
racism involved in their decision to
keep Danny ran white I think their
decisions are all entirely business
based but although I think you can grow
a business perspective I'm not entirely
sure they made the right call especially
considering I mean to bring up the
Mandarin and the ancient one again they
had two characters who really should if
they were going to be true to the source
material should have been played by
Asian actors and work again as I said
there were reasons for that and I would
say not entirely invalid ones but you
couldn't throw a bone back to the
community that you kind of took two
roles away from I just sort of arrived
from myself on balance I think it would
have been ultimately the better call not
by a massive margin like I said there
would have been problems no matter what
I think bringing this character to the
screen
he's a surprisingly problematic
character if you actually dig down into
them in into what's going on so that's
what kind of where I land on it what are
your thoughts on this thing whatever you
thought drop a comment a polite one
please down in the comments I don't want
to have to close the comments on this
I've never done it before but
if the tone is anything like it was when
I dared to bring up race in regards to
ghost in the shell then I am expecting
any kind of down votes an absolute
disaster in the comments section
could you pleasantly surprise me and
keep it civil I'm not saying don't have
the conversation I'd actually like to
see the conversation but I I kind of
like to see a civil one so again with
great trepidation I'll ask whatever your
thoughts are drop something down on the
comments let's talk about it politely
again leave but don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter and
councillors descaler listen of
counseling these podcasts available on
iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]